he hit you get like no backing out
you're doing this
yeah there's no backing out i think it
hit me like about what 34 rehearsals ago
I was just like crap i'm actually doing
this show no backing out like I'm going
to do with the right hands and I'm gonna
love it yes I'm gonna love it
the dazzled at all Carol what's he been
like so far
easy part student he's been amazing
nothing but amazing honestly when you
get a call that this is not the official
you're going to do the show well they've
been asking for me to be on the show for
like five years ago and with training I
like in the Olympics I couldn't take
that time off but now that I'm taking a
mental break and everything I can do the
show so i decided i was going to do it
before the olympics and then we finally
just like sign the papers and everything
after so quickly pants busy couple weeks
for you so you kind of hoping that
everyone from home can just kind of move
on and help you get that mirror ball
trophy
yes you know that's what I think one of
the things that's going to really help
me being on the show is you know there's
so many other important things issues
going on in the world and you know
hopefully this helps and help put people
in a different mind perspective of me
and you know just move on move forward
he's a great guy and I really want
people to be able to see that and like I
said give him a second
can I feel like dancing with the stars
is all about Redemption but he's wanted
to do this before that you know before
all this stuff happened and I think he's
genuinely talking on your ID genuinely
does want to do well and I hope people
really see the Ryan that I've seen in
rehearsals the last couple weeks so you
have